Speaker 1: I am going to play for you video
of Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity's
sulking recognition that extremist Republican
secessionist election denier Kerry Lake lost.
I really took pleasure in Kerry Lake losing, you
know, when it came to someone like Don Bolduc,
losing in New Hampshire to Maggie Hassan. I was
glad because Bolduc is a disaster and Hassan is
fine. And the better choice was Hassan. But I
didn't take a deep, visceral pleasure in it.
I take a deep, visceral pleasure in Kerry Lake's
loss because she is so extreme and she was so
arrogant in her being extreme and she was so
confident she was going to win and Trump was
so confident she was going to win and it really
would have been a disaster. I also have friends
in Arizona who were really hoping she would
lose. So I'm glad. All around here is Sean
HANNITY. While wrapping up an interview with Adam
Corolla, offhandedly mentioning, I don't know,
I guess they kind of called it for Katie Hobbs,
who, by the way, shouldn't even have been running.
And I'll address that in a moment to check this
out. Land safely and be alive. You know what?
Speaker 3: I think that says it all. Adam
Carolla, as always, we appreciate you being
with us. Thank you, sir. All right. Apparently,
they did have a drop in Arizona. And Fox is
projecting that Democratic secretary of state
who should have recused herself, has been
elected governor of Arizona straight ahead.
Speaker 1: Yeah, apparently. I don't know.
They're telling me something like the decision
desk called the race. I don't know. There was a
dump. There was a vote dump. She shouldn't even
have been running. So this is this is great.
I absolutely love this. And on the entire. She
shouldn't even have been running thing. Listen,
if you want to seriously talk about when a
secretary of state runs for governor, should
there be some kind of special circumstance where
they have to go through a certain distancing from
how the election is run? Because it's absolutely
true. Secretaries of state to different degrees in
different states are involved in the running of
the election. And if they are candidates in the
very election, they are helping to run. You can
argue that's a conflict. I am more than willing to
explore that and figure out what sort of general
rules should there be when a secretary of State is
a candidate. But Brian Kemp was secretary of state
in Georgia when he ran for governor against Stacey
Abrams, and none of these Republicans said a word
about it. And when Kemp actually worked to close
down early voting, reduced polling places, all of
that stuff, Kemp was actually doing it. And then
Stacey Abrams said, hey, you know, some of this
stuff is like a little bit sketchy because this
guy is a candidate and he's also making these
decisions. All of a sudden, these very same
Republicans, they didn't say, well, Kemp shouldn't
even be running because he's secretary of state.
They came out and said, Oh, Stacey Abrams is an
election denier. Stacey Abrams is an election
denier. So they are complete and total hypocrites.
Complete and total hypocrites. They are pathetic.
And I just love I mean, look at look at this face
from HANNITY. Look at this sulking face. I don't
know. They're kind of telling me something about
a vote down, but I don't know. They say she won,
but she shouldn't even have been a candidate.
Okay, great stuff. Good thing, Kerry like lost.